Anchors away and put on a happy face,
because we have episode 5
of "American Horror Story".
In this video, we'll be
breaking down the latest episode,
and you'll want to stick around
to the very end for my theory on
why some ghosts are
reborn at Camp Redwood,
and why there are some we never see.
So heads up, because here we go.
The episode begins in 1980, four years before
Brooke and the gang arrive at Camp Redwood.
We are here with Nurse Rita, or as we've
come to learn in episode 3, Donna Chambers.
And for the purposes of this video,
I'm just gonna keep calling her Rita.
She's on a stakeout, trying to find out
where her father has been disappearing to,
after her mother told her
that he's been sneaking out.
And judging by the amount of cigarette butts outside
her car, Rita has been here for quite some time.
For those of you really paying attention, Rose Royce's "Love Don't Live Here Anymore" plays in the background,
which has such lines as "You abandoned me", foreshadowing the death of her father.
And speaking of her father, we see him get
out with a woman who definitely isn't Rita's mom.
Rita demands that her father open the door,
thinking that some hanky-panky is happening,
but something far worse is on the other side:
the mutilated body
of her father's victim.
Now Rita has some balls, instead of
getting the hell out of there, she's like,
"Man, I gotta check this shit out."
On the wall are conveniently
Polaroids of all of her father's kills.
Men, women, black, white, it doesn't matter to him.
And around the room, you may have
noticed that he keeps mementos of his kills,
like earrings, ties, belts, handkerchiefs, and sunglasses.
When the mutilated woman so rudely
interrupts Rita, she tries to stop the bleeding.
Um, Rita, her intestines are out.
Before she's interrupted by dad.
And I love how this brand of
bleach is just called "Bleach".
We learn that David, Rita's father,
has spent his entire life as a killer.
And what he's about to say starts
Rita on her journey to prove that
serial killing is learned, not
something that you're born with.
Rita only knows the father who loved and
raised her as a child, not this evil psychopath.
She doesn't want to believe someone she
loves so much can be capable of so much evil.
She does disclose to him that she's a psychologist,
so I think we can put to rest theories that
she was lying about being one when
she first went to meet Jingles in episode 3.
She tells him he
has the ability to change.
But before she can change his mind,
he stabs himself in the neck.
This whole intro section gives us
valuable insight into Rita's motivations.
She wants to prove to everyone that killers
can change, that they can be redeemed.
It's the same speech she gave to Jingles in
episode 3, telling him it's not his fault.
Society, war, trauma, play crucial roles in
whether someone will be a killer or not.
We also saw this echoed with
Richard Ramirez's backstory.
He's constantly traumatized as a child, even
witnessing his cousin kill his wife right in front of him.
If Rita can prove her theory right, she herself
gets her own redemption and peace of mind.
She so wants to believe some
external factor made her dad kill
that she's willing to release a serial killer
from jail just in order to prove her point.
It's really messed up and I'm here for it.
We're back where last episode left off with Rita
having seen Ricky resurrect from the dead.
He tells her that he was raised by the Unholy One,
and that Satan showed him everything about her,
how she released Mr. Jingles,
which led to the deaths of several counselors,
pranksters, and even a porn producer.
He calls into question her
very reason for being here,
contradicting her theory by
saying that evil is born within you.
The ghost of her father even says,
Meaning if he was evil, it would
pass on to her. She is his seed.
He then asks her to follow in his footsteps,
so it'll be interesting to see if she does.
It's also interesting to note
here that Ricky doesn't kill Rita,
which leaves me wondering
if this was at Satan's behest.
We've seen striking similarities between
Ricky and season eight's Michael Langdon,
but no hard connection
other than Satan between the two.
Outside the burning wreckage of the porn
producer's car, Xavier goes full psycho,
telling everyone that they need to burn
everything as some sort of signal fire.
And it's ironic he's obsessed with fire,
since he was put in an oven last episode.
He's knocked out by Margaret,
who says he could harm someone,
but knowing that Margaret
was the secret killer all this time,
she's likely making excuses to
get some more kills under her belt.
Back in the cabin, the others decide what
to do next, with Margaret taking control.
Notice how she still has the gun,
conveniently out of bullets, according to her.
And the deer antlers, which make her
look like some sort of horned demon.
Of course, they decide the stupidest
plan of action, which is to yet again split up,
and who do they make go with Margaret?
Yes, the guy who just a few hours ago was impaled
with a spike and had to be resuscitated with adrenaline.
So Chet and Margaret head off, leaving Brooke
and Montana alone with a passed out Xavier.
Montana grabs a hatchet and is
about to kill Brooke, but she chickens out.
Remember that Montana wants Brooke dead
because she believes her responsible
for the death of her brother Sam.
Brooke runs out after seeing Ray, who we
know was decapitated at the end of episode 3.
If you recall, Ray's last line at the end of the episode was, "Suck a nut Camp Redwood, see you in another life".
Well, another life sounds about right,
as Ray has mysteriously come back to life.
And he shows the same symptom as the
hitchhiker from episode 1: a loss of memory.
Chet and Margaret row, row, row their boat,
and at least Margaret didn't make him row.
Hey, on the bright side, Chet, you now
probably qualify for the Paralympics.
Margaret gets on the topic of death,
probably not the best thing to discuss
after multiple people have been murdered,
but she wants to know if Chet will repent
and ask for forgiveness before she kills him.
He doesn't, and then we get the most
brutal paddle scene since "Animal House".
"Thank you, sir, may I have another?"
She attaches an anchor to his legs
and makes sure to cut off his ear
to keep up the charade that it's
Jingles responsible for these deaths.
Ray and Brooke have headed to the
cafeteria in the hopes of evading Jingles,
who they've heard in the woods.
Remember that Jingles mysteriously
vanished after Margaret shot him,
but with Ricky and Ray coming back
from the dead, who the hell knows now.
Now, this scene doesn't offer a lot in
the way of moving the plot forward,
but we do get a lot of character
development for Ray and Brooke,
even a little kiss between the two,
which I predicted in episode 1.
Brooke tells us that she always had
to fake who she was in order to fit in.
That's how she met
Joseph Cavanaugh, her fiancé.
Even telling Ray that
she never really loved him,
which calls into question if she actually did sleep with Sam, Montana's brother, the night before the wedding.
I like to think she didn't.
And the two do what any sane people
would do during a killer rampage: bang.
Rita arrives to the cabin after being
scared shitless by Richard Ramirez,
and lets it out of the bag that
she was the one to release Jingles.
Xavier is pissed because his career is ruined,
although there is still
that porno of his around.
Rita says that if they can get to her car stashed away
in the staff parking lot, they may be able to get away.
But Xavier attacks, jeopardizing a
career for him, even in radio.
We see Ray and Brooke post ghost sex.
Now is it just me or was Brooke not too
thrilled about her first sexual encounter?
You know what they say:
Once you go ghost ...
She goes to the fridge, still thirsty, only to
find Ray's decapitated head from episode 3.
And after finding it, she tells Ray,
Now, this is important, because in traditional
slasher films, the virgin always survives.
But we just found out
she lost her V-card.
But is it really losing your
V-card if you have sex with a ghost?
So keep that in mind as we go along.
Brooke runs back to the cabin
and we stumble upon Montana,
who looks to be preparing a tent.
She's wanting to make her getaway.
Brooke tells Montana about Ray, but
before she can barely get a word out,
Montana smashes in
her face with a flashlight.
It's 20 minutes till sunrise and
as predicted in my last video,
because this episode
is entitled "Red Dawn",
we'll likely be seeing the rise of a
bloody new day at Camp Redwood.
Montana beats the crap out of Brooke
and finally reveals her true intentions,
showing us how she saw
her at Perfect 10 Aerobics,
and that she was the one to
give Richard Ramirez his blade.
We also get another brief discussion
on whether Montana had it in her to kill,
which echoes the question this season is
posing on whether people are born with evil or not.
And Montana is introduced to one
of my favorite bands: Radiohead.
Rita runs into the nursing station to
escape Xavier, when she runs into Jingles.
He's not too happy he's been brought here, taking
out bullets from his last encounter with Margaret.
Rita reiterates the driving
force of all her decisions.
And this question is
answered with Jingles.
He was never a killer,
outside the war, at least.
It was Margaret and the mental
institution that turned him into this monster.
Not wanting to live with the guilt of
what she's done, she asks him to kill her.
But Jingles knows it'll
be worse for Rita if she's alive.
Montana has gone full psycho, seems to be a recurring theme this season, and battles it out with Brooke,
when we stumble upon Margaret
and Jingles at the archery range.
He's not too pleased that she's
been pinning all these murders on him,
and just when it seems
like he'll have his revenge,
Xavier shoots him with
a shitload of arrows.
When he goes over to check on
Margaret, he's brutally stabbed by her,
which makes me wonder: If he comes
back to life, will he still have those burns?
And will he make a deal with
the devil to get his life back?
And that seems to be what's
happening with Ricky and Jingles here.
Ricky is offering him a deal:
accept Satan as his master to be reborn.
Hallelujah, it's finally morning at Camp Redwood,
after almost 4 episodes completely set at night.
The kids have arrived for camp and
holy crap, Montana and
Brooke are still fighting.
Brooke ends up killing
Montana in front of the children,
and Margaret pins all
the murders on Brooke.
Now this is interesting, because she probably knows that Jingles has made some sort of deal with Ricky.
She was there at the archery range and that pinning it all on him may not work anymore since well, he's not there.
Brooke is the next logical choice.
As police and emergency
services arrive at Camp Redwood,
Brooke is taken away,
and Ray's blood pressure is taken.
But since he's dead, there's no reading.
Forensics finds Ray's head in the fridge, and
when he's taken off Camp Redwood's property,
he's magically brought back,
unable to leave the grounds.
Now, whether or not his physical body
leaves the grounds we're not sure,
but it looks as though there's a distinction
between ghosts like Jonas Shevoore,
aka Jason Voorhees if you
rearrange the letters in his name,
and that of Ricky and Jingles.
Why is it that Ricky and Jingles
get to leave but not the others?
The clue lies in Ricky's earlier question
to Jingles: Would he accept Satan?
Perhaps in return for accepting Satan, you
are allowed to leave Camp Redwood reborn.
And if you don't or aren't even offered, you stay at
Camp Redwood in what Montana calls "purgatory".
Also, bonus points if you caught the
Ghostbusters reference, a 1984 movie,
when Montana says, "There
is no Montana. Only Zuul."
The episode also leaves us with
Ricky and Jingles off to Los Angeles.
Now, my best guess as to where
they're going is the satanic cult.
In season 8, Michael stumbles across this cult in Los Angeles, so it seems like the logical place they would go.
We also don't know where Rita went. Her work isn't done, and she's struggling with all the deaths she has caused.
Perhaps she will now seek her own
redemption and try to go after Jingles.
And this theme of redemption may
just be what it takes for our campers
to release them from
this cycle of purgatory.
Every character who has
come back as a ghost so far
has some sort of traumatic past
they want to be redeemed from.
This is why we see some people
return as ghosts and some not.
And I'm sure this isn't the last we'll see of Brooke,
who was seen being taken away by police.
Episode 5 puts a whole new spin on the show
with characters branching out from Camp Redwood,
so it'll be interesting to see how the
next few episodes tie everything together
and solve some of our
most burning questions.
Thanks for giving the video a watch.
Make sure to like and
subscribe with the bell on.
I have a lot more AHS videos on the
way, so you don't want to miss it.
Be sure to leave your comments
and theories about the show below,
and you can also reach out to
me on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember,
Daddy loves you very much.